For this problem we’ve been tasked with finding
the longest common substring. The longest common
substring is going to be the longest
substring found in two or more given strings.
Let’s go through an example and be pretty clear.
So here referring two words that I’m not going
to pronounce and if you look closely the longest
sequence of characters that they’ve in common
can be found right here APACH. There is no
other substring longer than five characters
found in both words. And in this problem
we need to find the length of the longest common
substring. So in this case it would be five
. So when I ease solution to this problem,
which should be really, really slow if we
calculate every single possible substring in
one word and check if its contained in the
other word. So I would start with T, then I might
do TA and then I might do AP, PA, AC, etcetera,
etcetera and then I go to three letters and four
letters and five letters and so on. And
each time I would check if it’s in the other word.
If it is in the other word, I would check to see
if it’s the longest substring I’ve found so far.
And I would update it. So this is pretty slow.
We’re going to do something a little different.
We’re going to write three functions. The first
function C suffix, finds the longest common suffix
. So given two words, like the ones we have here,
the longest common suffix would be either the
empty string or none. That mean there is no suffix
they have in common. But if we ignored,
the last few characters let’s say we had this,
the longest common suffix is going to be APACH.
So we’re going to find a function that finds a
suffix, which is going to be a step in the direction
of finding the more general longest common
substring. The second function we are going
to write creates a risk of all the prefixes for a
given string. So if we take in a word say,
CAT and calculate the prefixes of CAT, we
will get a list exactly like this one. Notice
that if there are three characters in the input
string, the list is going to be of length three.
And the last function is going to find the length
of the longest common substring. The way we’re
going to do that is by finding the largest common
suffix of all the prefixes. So we’re going to go
through each prefix, calculate the largest
common suffix, and then keep track of the
largest one we found and the length of the largest
common suffix of all the prefixes quite an
awful is going to be the longest common substring.
So let’s get coding this. So ever in my function
decoration for the common suffix. And one thing
that was noted in a hint is that we’re probably
going to want to cash the results of this function
in a chart to save time and be more efficient.
So let’s create that chart and then we’re
going to check in the first line of our function
whether or not we can reuse a value that we’ve
already calculated. This is called memoisation.
So here I make sure that X and Y are in the empty
string and if they aren’t I’m going to check the C
if the last value in each string is matching. If
they do match, my total length of the common
suffix is going to increase by one because the
last characters match. And then I’m going to
recursively call C suffix on everything, but
the last character in the string. So five CAT
and HAT, the first recursive call is going
to check the T in CAT and the T in HAT.
We’re going to see are they match at one and then
recurse on CAT and HAT do the same thing? Recurse
in C and H were not going to find a match, so
we’re going to return the answer. And of course
we have to remember to update our chart if we did
find the answer. And that’s the common suffix.
let's move on to the next one and as spoiler each
of the remaining functions is exactly one line
long. So here is the code for a prefixes function
. As a reminder, it takes in a string and outputs
a list of all the prefixes for that string. So
let’s take a look at this output. Given an input
of CAT we have C, CA, CAT. If we are going to
relate this to our code, CAT is X and we want to
see what substring operations we can do on X
to get these strings. So here we’re going to
return everything from index 0, remember its
0-1-2 to 1, not including the 1. So it’s just
going to be the first the 0 character. If we
increment that by 1, we’re going to get the
Increment by 1 again and we get the T
. And so what this was comprehension does
is it goes from 0 to the length of X, so
its going to go from 0 to 2 and we’re going to
take the substring from the beginning all
the way to I plus 1, so its going to go to
1-2-3, just like we have here. Pretty simple.
So given our two functions we’re going to rate L
substring. And as I said before, this is going to
be the maximum length of the common suffixes for
all the prefixes both X and Y. If you didn’t
follow along the code, it’s probably going to be
clear. So here I’m taking the maximum of the list
generated by this comprehension and what we’re
going to do is find every combination to prefixes
for X and Y together, find the common suffix of
them and the maximum of that list is going to be
the longest common substring of the entire word.And
that is how you find the longest common substring.